One,
>> Two, three, three.
[APPLAUSE]
>> And
with that, three years of construction and
anticipation are over.
The David A. Tepper Quadrangle,
a 315,000 square foot building,
the largest building on campus is open.
And Tepper himself was here for
the ceremonies.
>> Well this place is fantastic.
So, I tell you not too bad,
not too bad at all.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Quad is much more than a new home for
the Temper School of Business,
it's the campus hub.
A space that represents
a unique model of education.
It's based on bringing
all students together.
>> Nowhere is the potential for
what's next more palpable then
right here in the Tepper Quad.
>> Five years ago,
we really came together with this vision
of doing a business school which
was just not a business school.
A business school that was just more than
a silo where you'd be in a corner of
campus and just do business education,
but a place where you really
would have people come.
>> With the needs of business and the
needs of the world really now converging
on the strength of Carnegie Mellon and
the Tepper School.
I think we are uniquely positioned to
provide the intellectual leadership and
to educate the next generation of
business leaders and entrepeneurs.
>> It's very much about bringing
together innovation with
business models to launch new
businesses and launch new innovations.
And through the interaction in this space,
we'll be able to stand up new concepts,
commercialize new businesses,
it's quintessential CMU.
>> Tepper Quad also include the 2,200
square foot Rohr Commons where you can
get a bite to eat.
Student will study modern languages and
digital humanities in the Askwith Kenner
Global Languages and Cultures Room.
Corner stone of the first floor is
the David and Susan Coulter Welcome Center.
This is where CMU visitors can sign up for
a campus tour and
meet with admissions officials and
student ambassadors.
>> That is to divide
the conference room into two.
>> Next door to that is the 600
seat Simmons Auditorium.
It's the largest gathering spot on campus.
You can find the Tepper Quad out here
along Forbes Avenue on the other side of
the street from the rest of campus.
This used to be a parking lot.
And now, it's the shiny new home of
the nation's sixth ranked undergraduate
business program.
Find out all about it
at cmu.edu/tepperquad.
And check out our social media channels
as we celebrate the big grand opening.